there are many ways to get the things
that we want for ourselves in our lives
but basically it all begins with how we
choose to think as you think so shall
you be seven little words that I think
are perhaps the most important things
that we can learn and master in our
lives
this old proverb notion that I become
what I think about all day long and once
you know that what you think about is
what expands you start getting real
careful about what you think about you
don't allow your thoughts to be on
anything that you don't want or that you
wouldn't want to have manifest or show
up for you in your life have a mind that
is open to everything and attached to
nothing
no one knows enough to be a pessimist
about anything and that each one of us
when we close our mind who what is
possible for us or what is possible for
Humanity closes off the genius that
resides and lives in each and every one
of us having an open mind doesn't
necessarily mean finding fault with all
of the things that you've been taught by
other it means opening yourself up to
the potentiality and the possibility
that anything and everything is possible
so having a mind that is open to
everything and attached to nothing
really means finding within ourselves
the ability to get rid of a trait that I
find so common in the contemporary world
do you know that most people that I meet
spend their lives looking for occasions
to be offended they actually are out
there hoping that they can find some
reason to be offended and there's no
shortage of reasons they're out there
everywhere the way this person dressed
of what the worst person said they turn
on their TV they hear the news they're
offended by this someone used language
that they didn't like someone doesn't
share the same customs at you and people
all day long in fact if you keep track
tomorrow you will find probably a
hundred reasons that you can go around
being offended but a mind that is open
to everything and attached to nothing is
a mind that says I'm never looking for
anything to be offended by and that
whatever anybody else out there has to
say
my response to that is that's an
interesting point of view I've never
considered that before you just watched
two amazing clips from Wayne Dyer take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life belief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]